Look, this one suits you too.Charlotte I
can't just say if that mistake made me feel awkward and run away during the match.When I was
taken in by the Black Clock because I was so nostalgic for the game, it was also a
game.  Even so, he kept trying, and this
time he won't give up.
So maybe that was because he was trying to open up to me in his own way. Hey brother,
look at me, I
'm a little embarrassed. You look really good in
my brother.  My impression is that it suits her much better than the dress she wore when we met,
but it's not too
familiar to me, it's just normal.But I guess I've never
worn a skirt this short before.I'm sure she's been
eating well.  Thanks to her, she's
healthy, plump, and smooth.
[Music]
Mr.
Len, no, it's not a problem. I need to calm down, and my
heart just stopped for a moment.
Is it okay to stop it so easily
?